hallo mein Name ist Luca herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen Video
von mir ich habe euch mal wieder auf
Twitter gesagt Freunde postet mal
irgendwelche Videos unter den Hashtag
Luca reagiert und da das heißt dass ich
dann darauf reagiere
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also in dem ersten Videos bisher
passiert das dann ein Typ vor seiner
Haustür steht und dann fährt ein kleiner
Junge lang auf einem Roller er bewirft
die mit einem Schlappen weil das ist
auch super geil dass er wirklich von
diesem Schlappen getroffen wird und dann
eilt ein Freund von ihm direkt zu Hilfe
und schreit
das heißt wir schauen jetzt mal wie der
Krankenwagen ankommt
so sehen die Krankenwagen bei uns in
Bielefeld auch aus
danke für deinen Blick aus dem Bus
[Musik]
coole Tasche
und auch coolen Schuh den du da an hast
[Musik]
und du siehst auch cool aus
luca du stinkst wasch dich mal ich finde
es sehr traurig dass du mir gesagt hast
dass ich stinke aber dieses Kissen
das ist das ist ein cooles Kissen
ist ihr Freund ich habe diesmal wirklich
nicht auf Twitter gepostet schickt mir
besonders bescheuerte oder bekloppte
Videos oder so ich habe einfach gesagt
schick mir irgendwelche Videos und dann
bekomme ich sowas
seid ihr noch zu retten
wenn ich so Dortmund Fans im Stadion
sehe frage ich mich eigentlich genau das
gleiche was ich vorhin gesagt habe
seid ihr noch zu retten beim nächsten
Video meine Damen und Herren muss ich
ganz kurz vorher sagen das hat sie mir
den Tweet geschrieben der Hund hat
versucht ein Leckerli zu fangen und es
hat sie in slow motion festgehalten
[Applaus]
ich schau mal ob mein Hund das hinkriegt
Freunde das heißt Balu kommt
ich weiß nicht was du mir damit
mitteilen wolltest aber ich glaube das
so die Pointe war dass ich mal wieder
five nights at Freddy spielen soll und
habt ihr da Bock drauf also das ist ja
dieses Spiel wo man in diesem Pizzaladen
ist und dann muss man da irgendwie
kontrollieren dass diese Figuren sich da
nicht bewegen und so und das hat ganz
ganz viele Jumps also sind ziemlich
heftiges Horrorspiel also wenn ihr das
wollt dann schreibt mal in die
Kommentare beim nächsten Video muss ich
wieder vorher etwas sagen und zwar hat
sie mir den Tweet geschrieben hey Luca
ich kann das noch nicht so gut also
bitte kritisiere mich nicht so heftig
sie spielt nämlich Klavier und ich würde
sagen wir hören uns das einfach mal ganz
kurz an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich kann auch Klavier spielen
also wenn ich mir das Video so angucke
und mir denke wenn ich dieses kleine
Mädchen da wäre würde ich mir denken ihr
seid echt Arschlöcher
ich meine schaut euch das an
also ja irgendwie ist es auch schon ein
bisschen lustig
komm in den shop.de ich finde es
wirklich ultra krass wie du das mit so
einem intusiasmus sagst wie du wirklich
hinter dem Shop stehst
das Freunde wird hi das wird die neue
der neue Werbeslogan für meinen Shop
Wochenende
das Wochenende ist fast schon wieder
vorbei
Dings ist es irgendwie ein neuer Trend
geworden dass mich fünfjährige kleine
Mädchen wissen in dem letzten Luca
reagiert Video hat mich auch schon
fünfjähriges kleines Mädchen gedisst und
jetzt schon wieder und sie zeigt mir
sogar den Mittelfinger
reingeschaut also ich meine reingeschaut
hin und her aber ich frage mich einfach
was das für ein komischer Schrei am Ende
war
wo kam der her
ich glaube wir wissen jetzt wo es her
kam
ich bin
Luca kommst du zu dem videoday ich weiß
nicht was der Tanz vorher sollte und ich
weiß noch nicht was ein eckenkind ist
aber ja ich werde bei dem videodays sein
und zwar bei denen in Köln und in Berlin
also bei beiden
ihr könnt mich bei beiden Treffen Frage
ist ob das jetzt cool ist oder nicht so
mir geht's sehr gut danke der Nachfrage
und wie geht's dir mir geht es gut
danke das ist doch wundervoll hast du
eben eine Frage an mich oder warum
machst du das Video warte mal was fragen
wie du eigentlich mein Kissen so findest
ich habe auch dieses Kissen mein liebes
Fräulein und ich habe auch noch das
Kissen in der anderen Farbe wir wissen
natürlich wo ist die Kissen zu kaufen
gibt
ich finde das Kissen auf jeden Fall
eigentlich ganz gut also ich finde es
ganz flauschig ich schlafe da immer
drauf wie findest du das Kissen also ich
finde die dass das Kissen ziemlich cool
und ziemlich ich kann ziemlich gut drauf
schlafen ja das ist ja toll aber du hast
mich bestimmt nicht nur bestimmt nicht
nur ein Video aufgenommen weil du mich
fragen wolltest wie ich das Kissen finde
was ich selber produziere oder gibt es
da noch eine weitere Frage und was ich
dich fragen soll oder wollte
wie du findest du eigentlich meine
Socken
sag mir das mal bitte
das sind
coole Socken
ich dachte gerade wirklich erst okay da
ist ein Typ auf einer Treppe mit einer
Flasche vielleicht macht er gleich
irgendwie ein Bubble Flip oder sowas
einfach seiner Freundin komplett auf den
Kopf
[Applaus]
solche Leute wie dich nennt man
Ehrenmann
am Gegenteiltag
dazu brauche ich glaube ich gar nichts
mehr sagen oder das ist einfach typisch
meine community
an der Stelle frage ich mich dann auch
schon wieder seid ihr noch zu retten
danke auch für das spannende Video wo
tatsächlich einfach gar nichts passiert
du bist unser bester und
lieblings-youtuber wir leiten jedes
Video von dir peace bei solchen Videos
denke ich mir immer so okay da sind
gerade irgendwelche Leute die eigentlich
ihren kleinen Brüdern oder Schwestern
sagen hey sagt das mal
weil Zena wenn Sie jedes meiner Videos
guckt und like also ich meine das wäre
cool und so aber ich kann mir das
einfach nicht vorstellen ich kann mir
auch nicht vorstellen dass mich dieses
fünfjährige kleine Kind hier kannte und
mir deswegen Mittelfinger gezeigt hat
[Musik]
das waren edit von BTS also von der
K-Pop Band wenn ihr mal wieder irgendwie
eine reaction von mir auf BTS sehen
wollt dann schreibt es unten in die
Kommentare weil ich habe euch letztens
gefragt hey was soll ich mal wieder
reagieren oder kam 99 % an dass ich mal
wieder auf BTS reagieren soll also nicht
nur auf K-Pop sondern diesmal
dementsprechend nur auf BTS also sagst
mir in den Kommentaren was ist das
nee das ist doch jetzt ein Scherz ne
nein das ist kein Scherz das ist ein
Scherzkeks
versteht ihr weil die sich auf Kekse
gesetzt hat
ja gut letztes video
ich weiß ich keine Ahnung Frau ich kann
mir das auch nicht also warum das mir
dann ich weiß es nicht an der Stelle
würde ich das Video jetzt allerdings
auch beenden meine Damen und Herren wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann lass mal gerne
einen Daumen hoch da Freunde schaffen
wir 40.000 Daumen hoch
das da wird dann das wäre dann es tut
mir sehr leid dass ich in den letzten
vier fünf Wochen nicht so regelmäßig
Videos hochgeladen habe wie ich es
vielleicht davor getan habe ich war sehr
sehr viel unterwegs ich war in Amerika
ich war in Spanien ich war in Holland
ich war Norddeutschland und ich war nie
so richtig wieder in Köln für eine
längere Zeit und konnte richtig Videos
machen das Ganze wird sich allerdings ab
heute wieder ändern also morgen kommen
meine Reaktion auf den neuen Katja Song
also freut euch schon mal darauf und
falls ihr sonst mal wieder irgendwas
sehen wollt was ich irgendwie machen
soll oder was ich vielleicht früher mal
gemacht habe was ich noch mal bringen
soll schreibt mir unten in die
Kommentare Freunde und jetzt
bleibt eigentlich nur noch zu sagen das
was jetzt hier vom Video das was jetzt
hier vom Video ihr könnt jetzt hier
meinen Kanal abonnieren oder hier unten
meinen Shop Auschecken ihr findet hier
zwei andere Videos und wenn ihr schon
Abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die Glocke
klicken dann bekommt ihr gewinnen
Nachrichten
[Musik]